especially beautiful faces in the in the
room
yes
handsome devils okay
um
just wanted to know one thing uh before
we get started uh as you all know later
today the president will sign the ending
forced arbitration of sexual assault and
sexual harassment act into law the bill
amends the federal arbitration act to
make it easier for victims of sexual
assault or harassment to go to court
instead of being forced into arbitration
by their employer this law will affect
the more than 60 million workers who are
subject to mandatory arbitration clauses
in the workplace often without realizing
it until they come forward with a claim
against their employer president biden
has long spoken against forced
arbitration clauses in employment
contracts and today marks an important
milestone in empowering survivors of
sexual assault and sexual harassment and
protecting employee rights the bill
would not have been possible without
bipartisan work including from those
members of congress who will be in
attendance today representatives bustos
and representative griffith and senator
gillibrand and senator graham also
wanted to note um it is aisha rasco's
last day in the briefing room
seats before yes
thank you for all of your work um
and she's going on i've already
announced this i feel like i'm
announcing news but it's been announced
um to host weekend edition for npr as an
npr listener i look forward to being in
my sweatpants and coffee and listening
to you this weekend so congratulations
and thank you for all of your work on
behalf of the american people uh with
that colleen why don't you kick us off
all right um so i wanted to ask you
about oil prices sure they're already
about 111 or so dollars now um pelosi
has come out also in support of banning
russian oil so
why keep the carb out uh
you know especially when oil with the
argument that
putin is
uh
is going to not benefit from um oil you
know what i'm trying to say yes i think
i do know what you're trying to say
uh well
our objective and the president's
objective
uh has been to maximize impact on
president putin and russia while
minimizing impact to us and our allies
and partners and i know you've heard me
say this a few times before but we don't
have a strategic interest in reducing
the global supply of energy
and that would raise prices at the gas
pump for the american people
around the world because it would reduce
the supply available and as simple as
less supply raises prices and that is
certainly a big factor for the president
uh in this at this moment it could also
it also has the potential to pad the
pockets of president putin which is
exactly what we are not trying to do so
as the president has said we uh carved
out payments for energy trade and
transport from our financial sectors
sanctions with that in mind um i would
also note that we are also take we have
been taking steps
to degrade russia's status as a leading
energy supplier over time that includes
of course uh shutting down nordstrom 2
or preventing nordstrom 2 from
operating that's why we're surging lng
to europe to help accelerate its
diversification from russian gas and i
think you've also seen european leaders
talk about the need to reduce their
reliance and to diversify
and we are continuing to look at other
options we could take right now to cut
u.s consumption of russian energy i mean
for us uh if you look at publicly
available data it's only about 10 of our
imports uh but again reducing the supply
out there uh would have an impact on
prices and on prices at the gas pump i
guess the question is if oil is already
so expensive isn't he already benefiting
from a very
from the from an already costly you know
price of oil how does he stand to
benefit if you continue
to allow that uh if it reduces further
it makes it more expensive um so i think
we look at it through that prism
go ahead on the cost of this i mean the
president has sort of braced american
people for this right he said that you
know defending democracy and liberty is
never without a cost so is it just that
banning all russian oil and gas imports
that's just a cost that he thinks is too
much for the american people to bear
well i think there's two different
pieces here banning
royal banning russian imports right or
uh what he has done is carved out
payments for energy trade and transport
from our financial sanctions uh they're
slightly two different things uh and the
president
the the the
volatility in the oil markets as the
president has been predicting and as you
referenced he talked about in the speech
he gave last week is a direct result of
the fact that president putin invaded
ukraine and that has created volatility
one of the the big reason of course that
the president announced the release of
the strategic of 30 million barrels from
the strategic petroleum reserve and the
coordinated release is to address that
and ensure we are doing what we can to
put more uh in the marketplace but again
our or his uh prism he looks at this
through is how can we maximize impact on
president putin while minimizing it on
the american people and president
zielinski has called on russia to be
stripped of its ability to vote in the
u.n security council uh does the u.s
want russia to be removed as a permanent
member
we don't see that happening
we certainly uh understand
um uh you know they have a permanent
seat on the security council of course
uh that is why it's so particularly
disturbing that russia given its
particular responsibility for upholding
the u.n charter is actively subverting
the charter charter and abusing its
position uh the fact is they have a
permanent we don't uh we're really
focused on isolating them really on
isolating russia and holding them
accountable and as you know that's what
we and our allies are are focused on
doing
president zielinski is
calling again for a no-fly zone over
ukraine is that something you're giving
any thought to at all
again the reason why that has not been a
step the president has been willing to
take or we have been interested in
taking is because a no-fly zone requires
implementation it would require
essentially the us military shooting
down russian planes and causing a
prompting a potential direct war with
russia something the exact step that we
want to avoid and the president of
finland visits tomorrow does the
president want to talk to him about
joining nato
well the president is looking forward to
welcoming the president of finland
tomorrow to the white house to continue
their conversations about enhancing our
strong bilateral relations i would note
that they have spoken twice in the last
few months once on december 13th and
again on january 18th
i would expect they will discuss the u.s
finnish defense relationship which is
very strong and in fact complements
finland's close partnership with nato
along with sweden finland's status is as
an enhanced opportunity partner for the
alliance which helps ensure strong
defense and close security ties in the
baltic sea region but it remains
for any country up to that country and
up to uh
members of nato to determine any path
forward there lastly russia has been
cracking down on independent media and
descent at home what's your reaction to
that uh we have seen that and are deeply
concerned let me give you some specific
examples because this journalist
yourself i think it will
you will hear it as quite uh jarring on
moments sorry i just want to find all
the specifics in here
um you for your patience
um
one second okay
okay um
the kremlin right now is engaged in a
full assault on media freedom and the
truth let me give you some examples
today independent media sites such as
echo muskie radio and tv rain are off
the air and threatened to block and or
they kicked them off the air and they
threatened to block online platforms
such as voa russia
they have uh we've seen russia prohibit
russian media from referring to what
they are doing in ukraine as quote a war
or quote an invasion or quote an attack
they are banning their use of terms even
allowing media to use only government
sourced information to report on the war
they've called a special special session
of the parliament to consider a bill to
make unofficial reporting on russia's
further invasion punishable by up to 15
years in prison they've arrested more
than 7 300 protesters some immediately
after they began to protest putin's war
of choice uh they've bought they've
blocked and shut down social media sites
such as twitter facebook and instagram
and they've limited the amount of
dollars citizens can take out of the
country what they are trying to do is
block any information about what they
are doing to invade a sovereign country
and they're taking
severe steps to do exactly that
good just follow up is the
administration moving closer to banning
russian oil imports
i don't have any assessment of that for
you i just wanted to note the difference
between them or that there are several
different components
of options i guess the question is
what's the calculus in waiting if it's
ultimately the step that the united
states is going to take well there's an
on there's a policy process that is
undergone for any decision that is made
sometimes those move rapidly and often
there are a range of factors that are
discussed as those decisions are made
the pentagon noted today that that
russian convoy that's about 40 miles at
least long is still stalled largely they
believe yeah does the president still
think though that ultimately russia is
successfully going to take
that continues to be their aspiration i
think the pentagon also noted that they
now have 90 of their military uh combat
power pre-stage at the ukrainian uh
border is now in ukraine they've
launched more than 480 missiles at
ukraine in the invasion that's about up
from 450 30 uh since thursday so they
are continuing to make uh take
aggressive steps and move towards their
ultimate objective which is taking over
kyiv and taking over the country any
assessment of timing for that i don't
have an assessment to offer from here go
ahead oh god is there any situation
where president biden would sit down
with president in person again so long
as russian forces are in ukraine
i i can't make an assessment of that
caitlyn right now they're invading a
sovereign country and continuing to
escalate every day we're never going to
take diplomacy ever off the table but
again now is that not the moment for
that why not rule out an in-person
meeting if his forces are in ukraine a
sovereign country again we have
discussions internally about what the
best steps are to de-escalate uh what is
clearly a a horrific conflict on the
ground now is not the moment we're not
planning a meeting between them or an
engagement or a call the president's
been very very clear about that but
we'll have those discussions internally
and way the range of factors quiet
thanks jen um we understand that new u.s
sanctions against oligarchs are going to
be announced this afternoon
individual oligarchs might be named yes
uh how
is the white house choosing which
oligarchs to sanction do you start with
the richest ones or the ones with the
closest ties to vladimir putin oh we
look at one of the big factors is of
course the proximity to president putin
we want him to feel the squeeze we want
the people around him to feel the
squeeze uh i i would i don't believe
this is going to be the last set of
oligarchs uh making uh them a priority
and a and a focus of our individual
sanctions is something the president has
been focused on and i understand that a
travel ban is going to be
one component of this announcement
what about boligard's who are already
here will they have to leave the country
immediately
uh let me check on that for you i think
we'll have some sort of backgrounder on
this to get you more details and the
president will have uh more specifics uh
himself in about 30 to 45 minutes
depending on how close we are in time
okay um
the
president announced the other night a uh
a ban on russian uh aircraft traveling
over u.s air space as far as you know
have there been any incursions on u.s
airspace by the russians since then and
what would the u.s do
if a russian aircraft were to violate
that airspace i'm not aware of any uh
incursions i'm certainly happy to check
on that and i can check i'd really point
you to the faa on that but um and i'll
see if there's more we can offer okay
and then
finally
uh you know we all saw the news about
the january 6th committee and um you
know their belief that that there was
criminal activity
i wanted to get your reaction to that
and also does the president believe that
former vice president pence should
volunteer to testify before the
committee
well uh let me first reiterate something
you heard the president say uh the
former president subverted the
constitution in an attempt to overturn a
lawful and fair election his app his
actions represent a unique and
existential threat to our democracy and
the president has been clear that these
events weren't a full investigation part
of this is what we're seeing play out
and what you just mentioned and has been
reported over the course of the morning
we of course respect the independence of
the department of justice that gives
confidence to the american people that's
how it should always be and they will
make a decision a decision about how to
uh move from here as it relates to vice
president pence i would say the
president believes that anyone who was
asked should participate in the process
of getting to the bottom of what
happened on january 6th good thanks jen
um on gas you just said that you know
less supply raises prices it's not in
our strategic interest to reduce the
supply we also know you know the
president just recently is yesterday
talked about increasing domestic
manufacturing to bring down prices on
inflated items like goods
so why not apply the same logic to
energy and increase domestic production
here
well there are 9 000 approved oil leases
that the oil companies are not tapping
into currently so i would ask them that
question is there nothing that the
administration can do to get
those providers back to pre-pandemic
levels do you think the oil companies
don't have enough money to drill on the
places that have been pre-approved
just asking
i would i would point that question to
them and we can talk about it more
tomorrow when you learn more do you
think that opening the keystone pipeline
and having more energy friendly policies
might do that the keystone pipeline has
never been operational it would take
years for that to have any impact i know
a number of members of congress have
suggested that but that is a proposed
solution that has no relationship or
would have no impact on what the problem
is we hear all agrees an issue during
that those years where it would you know
take to bring down prices as you're
saying we should just continue to buy
russian oil well again jackie i think
you're familiar with the number of steps
we've taken a historic release from the
strategic petroleum reserve
well we can well let me finish what we
can do over time and what this is all a
remain reminder of in the president's
view is our need to reduce our reliance
on oil the europeans need to do that we
need to do that if we do more to invest
in clean energy more to invest in other
sources of energy that's exactly what we
can do to prevent this uh from happening
in the future we welcome any republicans
from joining us in that effort go ahead
as long as we're buying russian oil
though aren't we financing the war
well jackie again uh it's only about 10
of what we're importing
i've not made any announcement about any
decision on that front but our objective
here and our focus is making sure that
any step we take maximizes the impact on
president putin and minimizes it on the
american people and anyone who's calling
for uh
an end to the carve out should be clear
that that would rise raise prices go
ahead thanks john on the oligarch
sanctions i know they haven't even been
announced yet yeah i'm wondering um if
you could tell us like if there are
criteria that you've laid out for them
to eventually get unsanctioned so the
idea being that you would incentivize
them to
pressure vladimir putin to end the war
by laying out certain criteria
that would
get them on sanctions that's an
interesting question i mean right now
obviously we're in the middle of an
invasion so i don't think now is the
moment where we are giving anybody that
sort of an off-ramp but i can certainly
check if there's more uh that we have
conveyed to them what about the broader
universal sanctions i mean same answer
that there's no real criteria being laid
out of like what steps the kremlin needs
to take for them to get on sanctions i
mean i think right in this moment are
marching toward kyiv with a convoy and
continuing to take reportedly barbaric
steps against
the people of ukraine so no now is not
the moment where we are offering options
for reducing sanctions and one more on
the domestic front the senator manchin
had laid out something of a counteroffer
to what the president had described
during the state of union on his
domestic agenda uh it was involving
deficit reduction uh tax uh tax reform
and uh drug price cuts and some climate
provisions have you heard from him about
his ideas or is there communication and
what did you think what did the white
house think of that proposal from
senator manchin there have been ongoing
communications with every member of the
senate democratic senate and many many
many republicans i'm not going to detail
those uh from here the president has
conveyed that
he sees a lot of components where there
should be broad agreement on uh in what
he has proposed he talked about them the
other night some of them is uh the the
ability to negotiate the cost of
prescription drugs everybody thinks the
cost of prescription drugs should be
lower uh the president certainly
believes in taking steps to reduce the
deficit he uh this this this government
we reduce the deficit over the course of
last year uh that's something he already
has a record of doing and obviously
taking steps to make the tax system more
fair is something he believes in uh but
there are a lot of components that
there's a lot of passion behind on
capitol hill and there need to just be
continued conversations about that okay
good i want to ask you about the
supplementing emergency fund request
that sent up to the hill this morning uh
yeah about a third of it would go toward
a medical counter measures the
antivirals the president talked about
the antibodies
do you see us getting to a point where
the availability of these treatments
might mean that vaccine requirements are
neither necessary nor justifiable
i don't think i can make a prediction of
that at this point in time i mean the
vaccine is still
the best and most effective way and the
doctors will say this right
to protect people from
hospitalization and death
the pills are
certainly an important development
scientific development but the best step
anyone can take continues to be to get
vaccinated a quick question follow-up to
jordan's here about um the manchester's
proposal bill back better than mentioned
says is dead is is the transformation
formalized here is it no longer built
back better now building a better
america
that is formal
but no one cares about the type the name
in the american public they care about
what's in it and what it's going to do
um and so that's what we're most focused
on go ahead jen thank you i have a
couple of them
on the potential oil ban yep it feels
like because you now have republicans
and democrats
calling on the administration to ban oil
from russia as you laid out there a
range of different options under
consideration what would the
administration need to see in order to
make a final decision
i need to see how tell me more on the
ground what what would need to happen in
order to prompt a final decision on an
oil ban i don't know that we look at it
exactly through that prism um obviously
we have not held back and taking uh
significant historic uh steps that are
uh crippling the russian economy uh
right now i think there's no question
about that and the president has led the
world in doing exactly that but what
factor we're looking at here is the
impact on
uh the gas pump for americans uh and
reduction of supply uh in the
marketplace a reduction of global supply
would have an impact on raising prices
so that's the prism look at it through
there is
there are some interim steps that could
be taken instead of a full outright ban
that would potentially mitigate the
costs on gas prices
is there a sense that this is at a
tipping point and that some of those
interim options we are continuing
kristin to look at other options we
could take uh right now to cut u.s
consumption of russian energy but in the
context of maintaining a steady global
supply of energy so that's what we're
trying to balance okay let me ask you is
there any discussion about sharing us
intelligence with the ukrainians about
what is happening on the ground in real
time we have been sharing it real time
okay and
is there a sense that
the communication has been enough
to give them what they need in order to
be in a defensive posture in order to
fend off the russian forces to the best
of their abilities
well without getting too far into
details of what we do uh for obvious
reasons um we have consistently been
sharing intelligence that includes
information the ukrainians can use to
inform and develop their military
response to russia's invasion that has
been ongoing in reports that suggest
otherwise or inaccurate the world is
watching as this convoy is lined up
outside
the u.s has been very clear you're not
going to send in military forces is
there anything the west can do to stop
the convoy in its tracks short of
military action are there any
possibilities that are under discussion
well one of the reasons the president
pushed to expedite the delivery or the
approval and delivery of
a security package over the weekend was
to give them the ukrainians more support
more equipment more defensive weapons
to utilize in this moment
but we are not
reconsidering or taking steps
that would prompt a war between uh the
united states and russia and if i could
there was a little bit of breaking news
as we were coming out there you may or
may not be aware of it ukraine has said
it's agreed with russia to create safe
corridors
backed by ceasefires to evacuate
civilians deliver aid is the u.s aware
of this will the u.s assist in this what
can you tell us we will continue to
assist efforts by uh efforts supported
by the ukrainians i obviously haven't
talked to our national security team
about this yet i will venture to do that
and we can get you all any more
specifics from here after the briefing
if that's helpful go ahead thank you jen
president putin spoke today with saudi
crown prince mohammed bin salman about
the sanctions russia is facing and
specifically about global energy supply
given the volatility of oil prices does
president biden have any plans to talk
to the saudi crown prince well a couple
of weeks ago i would note um brett
mcgurk and thomas hochstein made a trip
to saudi arabia to talk about a range of
issues including uh global markets
global energy markets as well as yemen
um and we will continue to have a range
of ways we engage with the saudis
president has no plans to talk to the
saudi crown i don't have anything to
predict for you at this point in time
zolensky has said russia's actions
clearly constitute a war crime uk prime
minister boris johnson also said that
russia's targeting of civilians fully
qualifies as a war crime the president
wouldn't go that far when he was asked
yesterday why has he been reluctant to
label russia's actions
well there is a process that we have
stood up a process internally an
internal team
to assess and look at um and evaluate
evidence
of what we're seeing happen on the
ground that is a standard part of our
process in the u.s government i would
note that we work uh very closely with
our international partners and we will
provide um any information that we uh
surface uh through that process uh you
know i think we've seen on the ground
that uh that uh uh reports of a range of
barbaric tactics of reports of of
targeting civilians that's all factors
that we look at uh and again that
interagence that process that has been
stood up would provide any information
to the
icc or any other international body
taking a look at this
go ahead
um
excuse me how are there any discussions
now or have you guys had been in recent
weeks recent days i guess it feels like
weeks
with european allies about preparing
staging zones for ukrainian insurgency
perhaps to provide training and other
assistance
well there's right now our focus is on
supporting the current ukrainian
government and leadership and
that includes expediting assistance
expediting military uh defense
assistance engaging closely with them
and uh will stay focused there
representative adam smith on msnbc said
that we the united states providing some
intelligence to the ukrainians but not
providing the type of real time and
targeting that you see u.s military
getting into war so why is arming the
ukrainians with stingers and doblins
appropriate but not providing them
targeting intelligence for well i think
this is similar to what kristen just
asked i would just say that there have
been a range of reports out there that
are false we can't get into details of
all of our intelligence sharing for
obvious reasons but we've continued and
consistently intense shared a
significant amount of detailed timely
intelligence on russia's plans and
activities with the ukrainian government
to help ukrainians defend themselves
we've been doing that for months this
includes uh
information
that should help them inform and develop
their military response to russia's uh
invasion that's what's happening or has
been happening go ahead aisha thank you
i know people have asked a lot about you
know the price of oil but i want to come
at it in a little bit of a different way
than the fact is that the price of oil
is high it is very unlikely to go down
uh anytime soon and more than likely
will go up what is the the the white
house looking at i know that there was
the strategic release of rule but are
there other things that the white house
is looking at to help consumers at the
pump maybe to you know wreck subsidies
maybe more biofuels maybe easing the
jones
what is the plan for americans we're
going to have to be living with these
high hole prices
well i would say first on the release of
the strategic petroleum at first to an
action as a process that will proceed
and a lot of that will happen of course
of the coming weeks so we haven't seen
obviously all of the direct impact of
the announcement that was just made two
days ago but a range of options remain
on the table i can't get into all the
details of those but the president is
quite focused on making sure that we are
taking
steps to reduce the impact to ensure
there's supply necessary out there
obviously tapping the strategic
petroleum reserve is part of that
engaging with global partners around the
world who may be big global suppliers
about uh putting more oil in the system
uh that is part of the discussion and
sure there are a range of domestic
options but uh there there have been
ongoing discussions and considerations
some of that you saw with the
announcement of the strategic petroleum
reserve uh release just two nights ago
what does the white house say to
american consumers like should american
consumers right now be thinking okay i'm
going to have to pay a lot more at the
pump going forward should they be taking
that into consideration when they're
buying cars or you know should they try
or saving their money like what should
they be doing practically at this moment
considering the price of gas is going to
affect them
of course it is as i've been saying and
that's why we've been focused on it for
weeks if not months
to ensure we are taking every step the
president is taking every step to reduce
that impact the release of the his
strategic petroleum reserve uh 30
million barrels that he announced just
the other night again that process is
just starting it's a bit of a process to
get that going and that will hopefully
have an impact and getting more supply
out there
but we would say directly to consumers
the president is going to do everything
we can to reduce the impact uh to make
sure that we are working with our
partners around the world to address the
volatility in the global oil markets to
consider a range of options that he can
continue to take to
reduce the impact that they're feeling
at the pump and this has been front and
center on his mind since the beginning
of this conflict
the there was a call with quad leaders
today uh india has a military
relationship with russia
is that was that discussed at all or is
there talk of you know talking to india
about that relationship that it has with
russia is there anything that the u.s
plans to do on that well what i can tell
you about the call and we'll have a more
uh comprehensive readout soon if it's
not already out is that
the president felt it was a constructive
conversation uh he asked uh members uh
he suggested or they all discussed i
should say having members of their
national security team follow up from
there uh but i'm not gonna get into more
details about the conversation beyond
that go ahead thanks dan i'm pivoting to
the supreme court yeah uh can you
respond to some of the criticisms that
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
laid out about katangi from jackson i
think he said that she won't shun court
packing and that she's only had two
opinions on the dc circuit level
sure
so as i think you're referencing uh
kentucky run jackson judge kentucky
brian jackson has obviously started to
have meetings on capitol hill
that have been ongoing um i would note
that as it relates to the first question
the constitution is clear that the
number of question of justices is a
question for congress not the judiciary
and a number of you have actually
pointed out this morning that during
justice amy coney barrett's confirmation
hearing she was asked a question about
court packing or court enlargement and
she said quote that is a question left
open to congress i'd also note that
yesterday senator mcconnell also said
that there was quote no question that
judge jackson was qualified for the
supreme court and earlier in the day he
said they'd had a good meeting i think
there's no question that as a judge who
has been confirmed three times
by uh by the senate uh someone who has a
long record um as both a um jurist who
has ruled uh in in the direction of
democrats and republicans uh that she is
someone who's eminently qualified uh for
this uh job which is why the president
nominated her
on the state of the union yeah the
president repudiated the phrase defund
the police and i wonder if you can talk
a little bit about the genesis of that
line in the speech was it about rising
crime in american cities or republican
attacks and there's also been criticism
you know that he did not talk about
police accountability more
in the state of being i wonder if you
can respond to that as well sure well on
the first part of the question uh that's
been the president's view for decades
he's never been a supporter of defunding
the police
he made that clear on the campaign
there has been attempts to
mischaracterize his position in the
position of frankly a number of his
democratic colleagues and
yes it is true that in the state of the
union the president felt it was
important to speak to
safe communities the steps that he would
continue to support
to ensure there was funding for local
police departments but that has been
his position for decades it was simply a
restatement of that
on the second part of your question
i would say that the president
has been
clear many times that he believes that
we need to continue to ensure police
departments have the funding they need
that there are strong relationships and
partnerships built with communities but
that there also needs to be steps that
are taken
to ensure there are accountability
measures put in place he was a strong
supporter of the bipartisan discussion
uh about police reform that
unfortunately stalled but remains uh you
know a consideration of an executive
order remains under under consideration
i would also note that there are a
number of steps that the department of
justice has taken banning chokeholds etc
at the federal level uh that uh that the
president is proud uh that he that has
happened in his administration go ahead
and jen i wanted to return to this
question of finding off ramps for putin
that we discussed so from your many
years in the state department in a
situation like this that's the first
thing that diplomats begin to try to
think about
um
you need something face saving
if you were going to get it to reduce
the amount of violence and going into
ukraine
um
what kind of ideas are you kicking
around here that might
provide a way for him
to find a more graceful way
out of this before you've got
the kind of large-scale civilian
casualties you're really worried about
yeah i think one david we have ha
provided many off-ramps uh to president
putin through the course of the last
several months i know there have been a
range of discussions about transparency
measures about positions of missile
defense systems uh that have been uh
undertaken uh for the last several weeks
it's going to be very hard
to have a um for diplomacy to succeed
without military de-escalation and
whatever we do we're going to do that in
lockstep with our partners and allies uh
secretary blinken is leaving today for
brussels he's going to meet with nato
the eu and the g7 allies and partners to
continue our close coordination before
heading to poland moldova and the baltic
countries um but again our effort and
our focus right now is continue to
work with our allies and partners to
implement these sanctions put the
pressure on uh and leave the door open
to diplomacy of course but it's
difficult to do that in the middle of a
of a war there is de-escalation if you
could get a ceasefire for example in
before
kiev turned into more of a ruin is the
administration willing to then suspend
some of the sanctions that they've
received i'm not going to lay out
conditions from here i think those are
conversations uh the range of
conversations if there are de-escalatory
steps that we would have with our
european partners and obviously
secretary blinken will be uh playing a
front and center role in doing exactly
that one last one for you uh president
zielinski in a news conference he gave a
few hours ago
said that the west should recognize that
uh where putin was headed toward he said
was berlin
his point being that he wanted to take
this war beyond
ukraine is that the administration's
current assessment based on what putin
has said in public in his conversations
with macron the president and so forth
i think we all watch the speech which
now feels like it was a year ago but was
only last week
where he
made clear he had
broad ambitions of what he wanted to
achieve
it is also true though that
nato has never been more unified thanks
in part to president putin's aggression
and
uh
there are a range of countries that are
exactly in that region who are nato
partners and allies and president putin
would have to make a decision to go into
a country uh where there is a nato
alliance where there's article five
obligations you know should he decide he
wants to proceed beyond uh so i don't
have a new assessment from here other
than
georgia they're not nato members
certainly i understand that but uh you
know again david i don't have a new
assessment to offer uh but uh we are
also uh closely watching of course what
presidents putin
does and is doing uh since he delivered
that speech last week but i don't have
anything new beyond what he has himself
said publicly go ahead i'm coming back
to the president's state of the union
speech on tuesday he said that
he wants to secure our border and fix
the immigration system that's a bit of a
shift from last year's um speech to
congress where he spoke more about
trying to find the root causes
of why people are migrating why was
there this sort of shift in messaging
kind of focusing on securing the border
and is that a new priority or has have
priorities changed on immigration um for
the administration
no i would say first the bill that the
president proposed on his first day in
office included smarter security
and border protections and also included
a more humane
path
for uh migrants entering the country uh
both of those remain priorities for the
president he believes that this the
immigration system is broken it's long
overdue to fix it uh he also believes
and worked on this very closely as vice
president that addressing the root
causes is one of the central steps we
need to remain focused on even as we're
trying to address the current
circumstances of the border why was it
important for the president to say to
you know advocate for securing our
border i know he's been criticized
heavily you know by republicans by um
you know certain folks on you know how
he's handled immigration at the border
so is that important for him well that's
part of his bill that he proposed so
it's consistent with his policies and
one last question has there been any
discussion on
ending title 42 i know we've talked um
the president even talked about it on
tuesday about how we're moving past the
pandemic this is obviously a policy
that's been kept in place because of the
pandemic has there been any discussions
on ending that
well that is a decision for the cdc to
make i believe dr wolinski said
yesterday that she's reviewing that
decision
so i can't get ahead of any decision she
makes but she is looking at that and
that's an assessment they make from the
cdc go ahead karen thanks jen um respect
the oligarchs and the sanctions you had
said earlier that you want putin to feel
the squeeze and the people around him to
feel the squeeze how does the
administration feel that these sanctions
could actually change his behavior and
result in de-escalation you know what
evidence is there that the sanctions
like this would work for what you want
to achieve right now well it's a factor
it's not the only factor right but what
we're talking about here is seizing
their assets seizing their yachts and
making it harder for them to send
you know their children to
to colleges and universities in the west
these are
significant steps that will impact the
people who are closely around
president putin it's not the only step
we're taking obviously the financial
sanctions and the steps we've taken have
have crippled the financial sector so
much in russia that they've kept the
stock market closed for a couple of days
so uh it's just an effort to get close
to the people around president putin
canada announced a new program to
expedite refugee arrivals and says
there's no limit on how many can apply
is there a conversation in the
administration about raising the refugee
cap to accommodate ukrainians that would
want to come here you know i have to
check and see if the cap would actually
need to be raised we have said that we
continue to be open to receiving
refugees of course that what our focus
is on given the vast majority of them uh
have expressed an interest in going to
european countries and neighboring
countries is being the largest provider
of humanitarian assistance in the world
something that we increased over the
course of the last several days and
samantha power made an announcement
about that and continuing to provide
assistance that way
but we remain open as well i think it's
just again important to note what the
preferences of the vast majority of the
refugees who are leaving ukraine go
ahead oh we got to wrap up in a second
go ahead yeah president zalenski earlier
said uh you know calling for no fly zone
again said if you don't have the
strength to close the sky then give me
planes the united states open to sending
more air support to ukraine again i'm
not going to get into more details of
what the department of defense may or
may not consider but what i will tell
you is that we have continued to provide
a range of defensive assistance
something we have increased only only
increased over the last several days but
we are not considering taking steps that
would put us in direct conflict with
russia is there any concern with you
know you laid out the explanation for
why he's steering clear of sanctioning
russia's energy sector at this point is
part of the calculation in terms of how
much to ratchet up um
you know worrying that putin will at
some point determine that the u.s has
already joined the conflict everywhere
but the battlefield and will retaliate
is that part of is that a factor in the
administration's decision-making in
terms of how far to go or is that
already that's just in the question well
the sense that putin may retaliate
against the united states whether
through cyber attacks you know some
other measure
is trying to avoid that and trying to
maybe not go
past a certain line potentially is that
something i would say that the sanctions
the financial sanctions that we have
issued uh are on par with what we have
done to iran uh they are significant
they are historic and uh they are
crippling the sector so i don't think we
have held back in any capacity aside
from making sure we're prioritizing the
impact on the american people so no i
would not say that's how we view it okay
everyone i'm sorry i i'm sorry guys
we'll do this again tomorrow and we'll
be here thanks everyone
i forgot about the mask
thanks everyone
i know
uh
um